Daryl I looked my woman in the eye
sockets I told her straight out I just
said it man I said it I said I said I
said
I said [__] hey guys hey girl how you
doing man you have a good time
food is infectious and exciting today is
people from all walks of life celebrate
becoming the seventh state to legalize
gay marriage we're here talking to
excited couples about how they feel on
this historic day oh hi hi hi uh yeah
it's a various start today for civil
rights and for gay Americans and
Americans all over the country
Mary
we said that to be a conversation you
know what I mean because we didn't know
this was going to pass that's so darn
fast so are you guys a couple are we a
couple come on girl Let's Get Serious my
name is Lashawn and this right here is
my sandwich it's a Samuel yeah and we're
gonna
[Music]
agree how long have you guys been
[__] well we've been three years
forever it's really important to know
the person who is the bride I am the
bride
well tell us all about your plans um
well you know we never thought it was
important to have a piece of paper so
there's not any plans we gonna get that
piece of paper yeah yeah
ah where do you think you guys will get
married oh we know there's a lot of
hidden costs in a way everywhere we
gonna get married over here and over
there and in the sky and on a cloud wow
it sounds like it's gonna be a big
wedding well you know uh yeah it's it's
it's that's a conversation
we really need to talk about whether or
not we think it's fair to even get
married when it's still illegal in so
many other states see look at him look
at him that's my man with his big hearts
that I'm sorry my husband you my husband
now well my husband now okay we just
don't want to rush into anything because
stuff gets overturned remember what
happened in California maybe I'm gonna
get a 14 karat ring the size of 14
mother carrots that's what's up doc
well you two certainly seem excited yeah
do we seem excited yeah okay
congratulations
together just we really just didn't
think it was going to pass it's gonna be
are we gonna have a house that's shaped
like a unicorn and we're gonna have five
little girls the name's gonna be etny
Carousel sequin Abercrombie and Phantom
and we're gonna have a little dog named
Ruffalo and the dog gonna have a cat
named myriad
nah seriously you gotta come back to the
bar right now I don't even know Claire
yeah I'm sorry you left your jacket yeah
well why don't you give us your new fat
ugly girlfriend wait I didn't even
remember yet whatever getting left your
jacket me again started in a river why
would I do that
I'm not fine
what
Megan leave me alone put your jacket
though seriously
everybody drinks for everybody as soon
as she comes over I mean who does that
you didn't come back to the bar you're
literally
how is that possible I can't be an
[__] I got arms and legs in the head
where's my
dad I have no jacket you want it no you
know what
why would I do that you know what I'm
not following you anymore I'm done over
it fine
Megan come back to the farm yeah
no pretty good
me again do you want your jacket no
seriously come back to the bar you got
that I'm gonna throw this jacket in the
water oh nice that's really nice what do
you want me to do me again damn kiss my
butthole okay good fine fine then I'm
going I'm leaving right now
God damn it
Megan no like seriously your jacket yeah
but it's your jacket though
there
[Music]
me again
I have your I have your jacket
[Music]
seriously me
there's no way that he can win no no so
anyway
um what'd you think of the season finale
Game of Thrones
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
I'm reading the books oh sorry sorry we
saw the first book and he reads slow
we could never talk about it
that's good okay
hey has anybody seen that new Russell
Crowe Thriller because let me tell you
sorry it's just we're going tomorrow and
I don't want to know a thing about it he
doesn't want to know a thing okay all
right sure yeah yeah yeah
who won the game
that I'm gonna watch it later
oh you're oh you have a DVR I got it
stop okay yeah
good
so yeah
what's the weather gonna be like
sorry it's uh we're having a barbecue
this weekend and I don't want to stress
about the weather no of course you don't
we just yeah yeah
hmm
[Music]
this dream being Casper all this stuff
I'm so sorry babe I just I hadn't tasted
him yet
I'm sorry looking forward to it you know
talk about the ingredients I know yeah
it's a surprise for your mouth yeah I
like that
oh uh
if you got you know that commercial with
it
okay
[Laughter]
nevermind
it's probably best yeah
oh
no
cheesecake
got cheesecake
I mean oh yeah you know what yeah I love
some cheesecake let's do that yeah yeah
yeah
I mean I've been watching my cholesterol
intake but what the hell right well I'm
gonna die someday anyway right what
honey wow are you kidding me really you
just ruin it every time I'll see you at
home wait a second
life was taking place
come on yes I'm here
I promise you'll never forget about me
yes
of course
promise we will take care of our little
girl
love her
because
[Music]
promise me you'll stay strong for her
yes yes
I promise
and promise me you'll never sleep with
another woman
[Music]
I hear you
promise me you'll take care of Mr big
fluffy tail yes
that cat will be
the most loved cat in the world
and that you won't look at porn
oh
huh
is that yes
no pornography Buster Brown says what
is that a yes
[Music]
yo better believe our heart watching his
hand girl
you love me right yes I love you yes and
we're soul mates right yes
so you will never ever ever think of
someone else while masturbating right
message received I don't understand is
that a yes
is that a promise your request has been
filed say you promise
please
forget about
huh
I need to hear you say it I say I Pro I
promise you promise you
you promise
say it
okay I promise no air quotes
I promise I promise
what are you promising I promise what
you said oh fine forget it yes I mean
we at least promise to go see my mom
every day
so zero pornography done
I like that
nurse
nurse fix my wife
[Laughter]
it's not all about you
[Applause]
have fun
dude I'm sorry we're late man it happens
man you should talk about how we're
supposed to be in the car at 6 45 I'm
like all right
tell me my dumb ass ain't sitting in the
car waiting until 7 15. okay when I
track my wife down 20 minutes later
she's stepping out the damn shower
talking about can I help you see that's
crazy right there Craig I looked this
woman in the eye I said
[__] you told me 6 45 you said that
yeah I said
[__] then I laid it out but you said
[__] though
hmm you said [__]
yeah
don't play games man just tell me
what's this it's like say what you mean
mean what you say is that so hard it's
like last week man we going out to
dinner right I'm like where do you want
to go she's like you decide oh I'm like
all right Outback Steakhouse she like
nah like straight up Chili's she's like
no no Daryl I named seven more
restaurants no Craig no he finally said
Taylor's the place I know she wants to
go in the first place right right she
looked at me she said if that's where
you want to go no she didn't because
that's where I want to go Daryl I looked
my woman in the eye sockets I told her
straight out I just said it man I said
it I said I said I said
baby I'm gonna take her back up to the
kitchen and show her the dishwasher
Daryl yeah baby I want a kitchen island
just like the one upstairs you're gonna
get it too
I love you
I said
[__] if you wanted to go to Taylor's
just tell her brother you want to go to
Taylor's okay you said that oh hell yeah
man I laid it out right I said I said I
said
I said [__] I'm the man of the house
you said [__] though you called your
wife a [__]
oh yeah okay Daryl where are those guys
so she's like why don't you rent a movie
we both like no she did after I spent 25
minutes in the goddamn block but so
Craig I looked this woman in her optic
stems and I said I said
but you said [__] though
yep
hey honey uh Craig just give me the
neighborhood tour
so then she's like I didn't know we'd be
doing so much walking no uh I'm like I
didn't tell you to wear those shoes she
said don't raise your voice at me what
dare roll
oh look this woman dead in the windows
of her soul
I said
[Music]
I said me
but you know
[Music]